es ist soweit morgen früh wird der
länder mascotte auf dem asteroiden rio
galanten es ist der höhepunkt einer
spektakulären mission rom gehört zur
klasse der erdbahn kreuzen asteroiden
und könnte der erde potenziell
gefährlich werden die mission will mehr
über diese asturien erfahren und daten
sammeln um ein schläger auf der erde in
zukunft zu verhindern klicks und science
fiction
hier gibt es täglich neue science videos
abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich
willkommen zuerst mal der hinweis auf
unseren live stream zur raumfahrt heute
abend um 20 uhr hier bei pixum von
diesem sofa der link ist in der video
beschreibung und unter dem hier oben es
geht um solche missionen flüge zum mars
mond und so weiter wenn er fragen dazu
habt schreibt sie gerne hier in die
kommentare
für mitgliedern pattons geht es übrigens
schon um 1930 los ihr bekommt die infos
per whatsapp und ihr unter dem community
tag zum thema schon 2014 war die
raumsonde hayabusa hat zwei gestartet
ende juni 2018 hat sie sie dann ihr ziel
fast erreicht den asteroiden rio die
japanische raumfahrtagentur jaxa meldete
dass die sonder sich nun 20 kilometer
von rio befinde und von dort aus
messungen vornehmen werde
das ganze spielt sich rund 300 millionen
kilometer von uns entfernt ab aber hugo
ist nicht immer so weit weg manchmal ist
er auch näher
er befindet sich auf einer umlaufbahn um
die sonne die die erdumlaufbahn kreuz
damit gehört er zu den potentiell
gefährlichen asteroiden die auf der erde
einschlagen können und diese mission hat
das ziel mehr über diese asteroiden
klasse zu erfahren
hayabusa 2 wird in den nächsten
anderthalb jahren den asteroiden
vermessen 2020 soll die sonde dann zur
erde zurückkehren und proben mitbringen
die bei einem dichten überflug
eingesaugt werden dafür wird sie mitte
nächsten jahres einen inspektor auf den
asteroiden schießen und beim überflug
das aus dem entstandenen krater
ausgeworfene material aufsaugen
zudem hat sie bereits zwei länder
abgesetzt die bereits spektakuläre
bilder von der oberfläche gemacht haben
mit an bord der deutsche mini roboter
namens mascotte entwickelt vom dlr
der aus einer höhe von 100 metern auf
den asteroiden absinken soll
16 stunden batterielaufzeit bleiben dem
länder um daten zu erheben
dabei nimmt die kamera mesz camp bereits
während des abstiegs bilder auf nach der
landung wird sie die umgebung der
landesstelle bis zum horizont in hoher
auflösung fotografieren und führt auf
der asteroiden oberfläche biologische
und physikalische messung der umgebung
und des untergrunds durch das radio
meter misst die oberflächentemperatur
sowie die thermischen eigenschaften des
oberflächen materials das
infrarotspektrum mikroskop mikrometer
ein instrument des institut
d'astrophysique spaziale paris ups
richtig ausgesprochen ermittelt die
mineralogische zusammensetzung der
oberfläche das magnetometer mag eine
entwicklung des instituts für geophysik
und extraterrestrische physik der
technischen universität braunschweig
wird das magnetfeld des asteroiden
vermessen ein heftiges programm
das macht mascotte an verschiedenen
orten dabei bewegt sich der bot mit
einem schwung am von ort zu ort die
gravitation des asteroiden ist nämlich
so schwach dass bei jeder anderen
fortbewegung die gefahr bestünde vom
asteroiden wegzufliegen überwacht wird
das zehn kilogramm schwere gerät von
köln aus vom dlr dem deutschen zentrum
für luft und raumfahrt dort gibt es auch
einen live stream auf denen wir in der
video beschreibung verlinken für die
wissenschaft wird diese mission wichtige
daten erheben neben den informationen
über möglicherweise auf der erde
einschlagen der asteroiden werden wir
auch mehr zu den ursprüngen des
sonnensystems erfahren hast du ihnen wie
ringo sind überreste aus der frühzeit
unseres sonnensystems heute abend also
unser raumfahrt livestream hier vom sofa
schreibt gerne eure fragen in die
kommentare oder auch whatsapp mit dem
hashtag livestream unter diesem link
hier könnt ihr euch den live stream um
20 uhr schon mal vormerken für pence und
mitglieder geht es bereits um 1930 los
den link zu diesem hang out werden wir
euch also den mitgliedern im community
tab den patriots auch whatsapp und
direkt auf bett schicken nochmal ab 20
uhr wird das team für die gesamte
clixoom community öffentlich gemacht und
wir diskutieren zusammen und fachsimpeln
zusammen und wenn er nie was wir
verpassen wollt dann da abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran